our speaker tonight was born in Bombay
educated in England and has been an
internationally acclaimed author for the
past 20 years along the way he took a
fling at acting and was also an
advertising copywriter for two or three
years in 1989 The Satanic Verses was
published and quite clearly it changed
his life
the Ayatollah Khomeini called for his
execution and established a
multi-million dollar award for a
would-be assassin and mr. rusty
thereafter spent eight years in hiding
in England with the help of the British
secret police he moved frequently
sometimes daily and this period was no
mere game of hide-and-seek three people
involved with the publication of the
tannic verses were attacked and the
Japanese translator of mr. Rusty's book
was killed fortunately in 1998 the
Iranian government lifted the death
threat on Solomon rusty along the way
over a million hardbound copies of The
Satanic Verses were sold alone in the US
and an estimated 5 to 6 million were
sold worldwide
mr. Rusty's new book step across this
line discusses his period undercover in
England for those 8 years
it's a remarkable mix of many subjects
among them anti-americanism as an
ideological enemy the 2000 presidential
election
rock music mr. Rusty's obsession with
soccer The Wizard of Oz Northern Ireland
and the Telluride Film Festival his
writing has been compared to Charles
Dickens to Vladimir Nabokov and
Scheherazade
he has also been cited as a logical
candidate for the Nobel Prize for
Literature it's a great pleasure to
introduce summon rusty to you
thank you step across this line is I
only managed one of these books about
every decade nonfiction
clearly is not the day job but every so
often I've one of those writers who has
always temperamentally felt the need
every so often to speak directly about
this or that that's going on in the
world and to join and to feel that it's
part of part of my interest as a writer
to join in the so to speak the public
conversation about what what's eating
everybody and so there are passages in
these book in this book which which do
that um the book is broadly speaking I
wanted to construct it not just to be a
kind of rag bag of the last decade but
to have some sense of a sort of journey
with me through that decade and so it
deliberately starts with a fairly
extended section which is which is not
directly political which is more
culturally oriented and and and in which
I discuss as was being mentioned
everything from The Wizard of Oz to
soccer you know movies music and so on
and then the book sort of plunges into a
tunnel as I as I see it that the second
part is it's called messages from the
plague years and I mean the plague years
of course phrase from Daniel Defoe but
but he meant it literally every is was
writing about of actual plague year this
is more metaphorical metaphorical use of
it but it's about the years of that
followed the Khomeini fad pardon I
thought if only to if only to never have
to talk about it again
it was useful to it was useful to pull
together some writing which which tried
to explain what it was like in those
years to be me I mean not just not just
what it was like to fight the the
campaign against the fatwa which you
know for which I had helped from all
sorts of people including many people in
the United States not just what it was
like to argue through the intellectual
and moral ideas that were raised by it
but just what it was like to be in my
shoes
which is of course people being what
they are people are very curious about
so so there's some of that in here and
then in in the way I thought about it is
the book then emerges from the tunnel
and if you like uses both those kinds of
experience both those kinds of interests
the broader cultural interest and the
particular experience that then happen
to this particular writer to look
outwards that what was happening in the
rest of the world not just you did stop
talking about myself finally thank God
and to talk about something else
and the last long section of the book is
is a long essay which gives the book its
title step across this line which is a
consideration of the place of the
frontier in American history in European
history the idea of the frontier both
literally and metaphorically in the
modern world and the changing sense of
the frontier from if you like the old
American idea of the frontier as a as a
place as if you like as the borderline
beyond which lay the future as a place
against which American identity defined
itself compare that to the Soviet Union
idea of the frontier the Iron Curtain
which was actually there to hold people
in you know the frontier as a prison
then the period which you could say
followed followed the end of the Soviet
Union in 1989 appeared where frontiers
fell where the world seemed to briefly
to become a more open place a more
optimistic place and now I guess we have
a lot of trepidation about that idea of
the open frontier because the open
frontier is also something through which
planes can fly and hit tall buildings so
it tries I'd wanted to write for a long
time about the frontier because my own
life has been in many ways defined by by
not just by my movement across frontiers
but also frontiers movement across me if
you like you know I was born in India
eight weeks to the day before the
partition of India and so grew up in the
aftermath of that drawing of a line
across across a continent and the
division of my family by it and of
course the colossal massacres that
followed and and you know that the
political trouble that in a way is still
going on as a result of that particular
active party
so I grew up thinking of the frontier as
a problematic thing arrived in Europe in
the early 60s to discover almost
immediately after my arrival the
building of the Berlin Wall and and to
realize that you know Europe too was
capable of being partitioned so
frontiers have been something I've spent
my life with and my reaction to that has
always been to try and skip across them
in a Voltaire used to say that writers
should should live near frontiers
because if they got into trouble they
could always cross them and there's
something which he had to do more than
once in his life and which doesn't work
anymore anyway I just thought I would
read a little bit from this book from
here and they're skipping around in it a
little bit and then we could talk and
this being Washington and so on I
thought I'd start by something I wrote
in in in January 2001 which is at the
time of the presidential inauguration it
occurred to me to write a verse for the
inauguration so this is it this is a
verse written with apologies to dr.
Seuss for some reason they didn't use it
it's it's called How the Grinch Stole
America every vote down in vaudeville
like voting a lot but the Grinch who
lived west of vaudeville did not for
voting was counting not just adding and
such but finding out if you amounted to
much in this case the question was who
in a pinch amounted to more did the veep
or the Grinch the veep or a creep
what a creep creep creep creep he simply
could not be outdone by the veep
but the veep was experienced he'd done
the big jobs he was smart he was smart
ass he knew all the knobs and the levers
and buttons that worked the state's ship
and the Grinch well rain knowledge he
was not to hit the president of India
the economy past he'd never been close
to the head of the class so far the poor
grid hadn't amounted to zip he just
hadn't counted it gave him the PIP his
father his eminent diet his own blood
compared to him Grinchy had proved quite
a dud and now that he'd actually reached
his big day ah counting the ballots
could steal it away and what was a
ballot was it silver or gold were they
counting up treasure a fortune untold no
just some dumb punch card they were
counting up holes oh the holes yes the
holes
oh the holls holls holls holls the whole
thing depended on circles of air not to
mention the half holes at holes that
weren't there
but that was it to be there and thought
that was fair all they would do was to
add up to count and they'd counted
they'd count and they'd count Count
count count and they'd probably end up
with a quite wrong amount if they go out
counting the grid shuddered if they may
just wind up electing the veep how to
stop it the Grinch exclaimed with a moan
and then he remembered he wasn't alone
there were grinches all over big
grinches and small
there were grinches in vaudeville and in
City Hall he knew some news grinches and
he could depend on these inky fellows to
shape and to bend their stories to help
him win through in the end
but the Grinch's would give him the edge
and the win were the great legal
grinches and grinches of spin so he
called on his cohorts my friends we must
grinch the election enough counting to
work do not flinch
we must grinch we worse Grinch we must
Grinch Grinch Grinch Grinch
we cannot be beaten by circles of air or
circles that only imagine they're there
every day that they cut them the total
will creep up it up until it elects that
old veep so they Grinch the election
they Grinch day by day until all the
options were whittled away they Grinch
tit with lawyers they Grinch tit with
writs
they split all the hairs and they picked
all the nits and when it came up to the
ultimate bench they Grinch tit away with
one final wrench they ordered all vote
Ville to give up its count before it
came up with that quite wrong amount and
the votes down in vote Ville they've run
out of steam tis the season to party to
heal and to dream why worry the
Constitution is strong the judges who
judge it could never be wrong the veep
may have won but he's lost and that's
that vote Ville accepts the hi judges
Fiat there isn't a holler there isn't a
scream think of the dollar let's play
for the team so everyone okay's the
Grinch's regime and things are probably
probably probably probably not as bad as
they seem
four whole years of Grinch - the Grinch
cries with glee the
only one person who can't snow that's me
can't understand why they didn't use it
let's just see this one that should give
you a flavor of different parts of this
thing
this is this is a piece that I wrote
sort of during that during the middle of
the of the years of arguing the case
about the fat bar because one of the
things that really concerned me was that
people both on my side and not on my
side tried to argue that what happened
to me was somehow exceptional but
somehow it was a one-off for an oddity
and and yes there was an odd aspect of
it which was the which was the aspect of
international terror that I think
probably was new but the kind of attack
that was being aimed against the Satanic
Verses was being aimed in those days
against a very wide range of writers and
intellectuals across the Muslim world in
particular and I kept trying to draw
people's attention to this and somehow
it was news that people somehow didn't
want to receive I think people who were
trying to defend me wanted to say that
something uniquely horrible was
happening to me and that's why it was
important to take notice of it and
people who wanted to to oppose me wanted
to say that I had done something
uniquely horrible and therefore the
ordinary rules of free speech and so on
could not be held to apply in both cases
people were trying to say that it was
unique and my view is that it wasn't so
this was a piece that I wrote to try and
to try and draw attention to the senses
in which it it was not just just me it
appeared in the New York Times in in in
July of 1993 the following news stories
are all taken from the first half of
1993 in Pakistan and elderly poet Arthur
Hamid Khan 78 is quoted as saying that
while he admires Mohammed his real
inspiration has been the Buddha he
denies saying this but is nevertheless
accused by mullahs of blasphemy in 1992
he had been arrested for insulting the
prophets descendants by writing a poem
about animals that the fundamentalists
allege
had hidden allegorical meanings he
managed to beat that charge but now once
again his life has been placed in danger
in Sharjah one of the United Arab
Emirates an Indian theatre group who in
1992 performed a play entitled corpse
eating ants which was held to be
blasphemous and who had been sentenced
to six years al sentences for blasphemy
appeal against the sentence some members
of the group are freed but one has his
sentence increased to 10 years and
another has his six-year term upheld by
the court in Istanbul one of the
country's most respected secular
journalists ogre moon Chu is gunned down
in the street
Turkish fundamentalists take credit for
the attack and the Turkish government
says it has evidence linking the
murderers to Iran the Interior Minister
is matt says Gein says that at least
three killings have been carried out by
a group called islamic movement whose
members have been trained in
assassination techniques quotes at an
official Iranian facility between Tehran
and Qom unquote in Egypt the assassins
who in 1992 murdered the distinguished
secular thinker Faraj Buddha are
currently being tried
however extremists bombings and killings
continue in Algeria the writer thar jaw
is one of six secularists murdered in a
killing spree by what the security
forces called Muslim terrorists in Saudi
Arabia a number of distinguished
intellectuals forms the country's first
human rights group within days many of
them are fired from their posts
including University professorships and
many of them are arrested and jailed
trials are pending in Egypt
professor Nasser Abu said who teaches
literature at Cairo University is
charged with apostasy because of his
criticisms of the Islamists
fundamentalists asked the courts to
dissolve his marriage since it is
illegal for a Muslim to be married to an
apostate the alternative would be for
his wife to be stoned to death as an
adulteress in Turkey 36 secularists
writers dancers musicians and artists
gathered for a conference in the town of
Sivas are burned to death in their hotel
by a mob of Islamic fundamentalists
which accuses them of being atheists and
therefore in the fanatics
you deserving of being burned alive the
United States has recently become all
too painfully familiar with the nature
of the holy or rather unholy terrorists
of Islam the sister of the time of the
first World Trade Center bombing the
crater beneath the World Trade Center
and the uncovering of a plot to set off
more gigantic bombs and to assassinate
leading political figures have shown
Americans how brutal these extremists
can be these and other cases of
international islamic terrorism have
shocked the world community whereas the
cases of domestic terrorism previously
listed have captured relatively little
of the world's share of mind I should
like to suggest that this imbalance in
our attention represents a kind of
victory for fanaticism if the worst most
reactionary most medievalist strain in
the Muslim world is treated as the
authentic culture so that the Bombers
and the mullahs get all the headlines
while progressive modernizing voices are
treated as minor marginal marginal or in
the currently fashionable phrase West
toxicated in short as small news then
the fundamentalists are being allowed to
set the agenda the truth is that there
is a great struggle in progress for the
soul of the Muslim world and as the
fundamentalists grow in power and
ruthlessness those courageous men and
women who are willing to engage them in
a battle of ideas and of moral values
are rapidly becoming as important for us
to know about to understand and to
support as once the dissident voices in
the old Soviet Union used to be the
Soviet terror state to denigrated its
opponents as being overly westernized
and enemies of the people it too took
men from their wives in the middle of
the night as the poet Asif Mandelstam
was taken from Nadezhda we do not blame
Mandelstam for his own destruction we do
not blame him for attacking Stalin but
rather and rightly we blame Stalin for
his stalinís in the same spirit let us
not fall into the trap of blaming say
the Sharjah theater folk for their
rather macabre sounding aunt's or
turkish secularists for provoking the
mob that murdered them rather we should
understand that secularism is now the
fanatics enemy number one and its most
important target
why because secularism demands a total
separation between church and state
philosophers such as the Egyptian foods
Acharya argued that free Muslim
societies can exist only if this
principle is adhered to and because
secularism rejects the idea that any
society of the late 20th century can be
thought of as pure and argues that the
attempt to purify the modern Muslim
world of its inevitable hybridity z--
will lead to equally inevitable
tyrannies and because secularism seeks
to historic eyes our understanding of
the Muslim verities it sees Islam as an
event within history not outside it and
because secularism seeks to end the
repressions against women that are
instituted wherever the radical
Islamists come into power and most of
all because secularists know that a
modern nation-state cannot be built upon
ideas that emerged in the Arabian desert
over 1300 years ago the weapons used
against the dissidents of the Muslim
world are everywhere the same the
accusations are always of blasphemy
apostasy heresy on Islamic activities
these crimes are held to insult Islamic
sanctities the people's wrath so-called
thus aroused becomes as they say
impossible to resist the accused become
persons whose blood is unclean and
therefore deserves to be spilled the
British writer marina Warner once
pointed out that the objects associated
with witchcraft a pointed hat of
broomstick a cauldron a cat would have
been found in most women's possession
during the great witch hunts if these
were the proofs of witchcraft that all
women were potentially guilty it was
only necessary for accusing fingers to
point at one woman and cry which
Americans remembering the example of the
McCarthyite witch hunts will readily
understand how potent and its
destructive the process can still be and
what is happening in the Muslim world
today must be seen as a witch hunt of
exceptional proportions
a witch hunt being carried out in many
nations and often with murderous results
so the next time you stumble across a
story such as the ones I've repeated
here perhaps the story tucked away near
the bottom of an inside page in in a
newspaper remember that the
execution it describes is not an
isolated act that it is part of a
deliberate lethal program whose purpose
is to criminalize denigrate and even to
assassinate the Muslim world's best and
most honorable voices its voices of
dissent and remember that those
dissidents need your support and more
than anything they need your attention
just just in case you were thinking I
was a serious person
I thought I would read you a brief
passage in in this period in in when was
this 19min 1990s but this is about 1996
I read this I think I suddenly became
aware looking around the kind of
cultural scene that there was a new
bizarre fashion for works of art movies
books plays cetera whose titles were
deliberately incomprehensible and and so
I wrote a piece about this called
reservoir frogs subtitled places called
Mama's and this is this is it is quite
short for the first time since the
decline of dadaism we are witnessing a
revival in the fine art of meaningless
naming this thought is prompted by the
US release of the British film
Trainspotting and by the opening of
Lanford Wilson's new play Virgil is
still the Frog boy
mr. Wilson's play is not about any one
called Virgil no frogs featured there in
the title is taken from an East Hampton
Long Island crow Fito to whose meaning
the play offers no clues this omission
has not diminished the show's success as
Luis buñuel knew obscurity is a
characteristic of objects of desire
accordingly there is no Trainspotting in
Trainspotting just a predictable
somewhat sentimental movie that thinks
it's hip compared to the work of say
william s burrows its positively cutesy
it has many admirers perhaps because
they're unable even to understand its
title let alone the fashionably
indecipherable agro of the dialog the
fact remains Trainspotting contains no
mention
of persons keeping obsessive notes of
the arrival and departure of trades the
only railway engines are to be found on
the wallpaper of the central characters
bedroom whence therefore this title some
sort of pun on the word tracks may be
intended early in Welsh's original
normal does offer a little help the
section titled Trainspotting at least
Central Station takes the characters to
a derelict railway station in which of
course there are no trains where one of
them attacks the derelict human being
who is in fact his father doling out a
goodly quantity of what Anthony
Burgess's hoodlum Alex at a Clockwork
Orange would call the old ultraviolence
clearly something metaphorical is being
reached for here though it's not clear
exactly what in addition Welsh
thoughtfully provides a glossary for
American readers rat-arsed
drunk wanker masturbator
thrush minor sexually transmitted
disease at least an effort at
translation is being made out about
incomprehensible ist's disdain such
coziness Clockwork Orange for example
how many readers of Anthony Burgess's
novel A Clockwork Orange or viewers of
Stanley Kubrick's subsequent film know
that Burgess took his title from an
allegedly very common but actually never
used British simile queer is a Clockwork
Orange
can anyone recall the meaning of the
film titles kyani scott c and power-cut
c and were there any secrets encrypted
in Lucy in the Sky with Diamonds or was
it just a song about a flying girl with
a necklace nowadays dreary old
comprehensibility is still very much
around a film about a boy man called
Jack is called Jack a film about a
crazed baseball fan is called the fan
the film version of Jane Austen's Emma
is called Emma
however titular mystification continues
to intensify when Oasis the British pop
phenomenons sing you're my Wonderwall
what can they mean I intend to ride over
you on my motorbike round and round
very high-speed surely not and how about
Blade Runner yes I know that hunters of
Android replicants in the movie are
called blade runners but why and yes yes
William s Burroughs again used the
phrase at a 1979 novel and to get really
arcane there's a 1974 medical thriller
called the Blade Runner by the late Alan
II nurse but what does any of this have
to do with Ridley Scott's movie
Harrison Ford runs not neither does he
blade shouldn't a work of art give us
the keys with which to unlock its
meanings but perhaps there aren't any
perhaps it's just at the phrase Cylons
cool thanks to those echoes of Burroughs
perhaps daddy cool himself in 1928 luis
buñuel and Salvador Dali co-directed the
surrealist classic Chien Andalou a film
about many things but not under Lucien
dogs
so it is with Quentin Tarantino's first
film Reservoir Dogs no Reservoir no dogs
no use of the words Reservoir Dogs or as
a for dogs at any point in the movie no
imagery dessert derived from dogs or
reservoirs or dogs in reservoirs or
reservoirs of dogs
nada or as mr. pink and company in the
movie would say [ __ ] nada
the story goes that when the young
Tarantino was working in a los angeles
video store his distaste for Fancy Pants
European otres like for example Louima
manifested itself in an inability to
pronounce the titles of their films Mars
au revoir lays off or defeated him
completely Oh
Reservoir lay-oh [ __ ] until he began to
refer to it contemptuously as you
guessed it those are Reservoir Dogs
subsequently he made this the title of
his own movie no doubt is a further
gesture of anti-european defiance alas
the oblique nosov the jibe meant that
the europeans simply did not comprende
what we have here as the guy in Cool
Hand Luke remarked is a failure to
communicate but these days the thing
about in comprehensibility is that
people aren't supposed to get it in
accordance with the new zeitgeist
therefore the subtitle of this piece has
been selected sampled from Lou Reed's
wise advice don't eat at places called
Mama's in the diary of his recent tour
to forestall any attempt at exegesis
author citing Dada isms erstwhile
esotericism opposes present-day mama
IIST obfuscation z' i confess it as a
title it means nothing at all but then
the very concept of meaning is now
outdated nerdy pre ironic welcome to the
new incomprehensible 'ti gibberish with
attitude
no I'm just good you just just a couple
of minutes and then we can then we can
talk as I said the book ends with this
with this meditation about the frontier
the frontier not just as a literal thing
but also as a literal thing the frontier
is a metaphor the sense of a sense of
the crossing of transgression of the
crossing of lines as as perhaps
necessary but also dangerous and and I
just want to read you the last couple of
paragraphs of the piece sorry I have to
keep changing my glasses but otherwise
either can't see you or I can't see the
book even before the attacks on America
I was concerned that in Britain and
Europe as well as America
the pressures on artistic and even
intellectual freedoms were growing that
cautious conservative political and
institutional forces were gaining the
upper hand and that many social groups
were deliberately fostering a new
short-fused culture of easy offended
nurse so that less and less was becoming
saleable all the time and more and more
kinds of speech were being categorized
as transgressive outside the Western
world across the Arab world in many
African countries in Iran China North
Korea and elsewhere writers and
intellectuals are everywhere under
attack and more and more of them are
being forced into exile if it was
important to resist this cultural
closing in before 9/11
it's twice as important now the freedoms
of art and the intellect are closely
related to the general freedoms of
society as a whole
the struggle for artistic freedom serves
to crystallize for larger question that
we were all asked when the planes hit
the buildings how should we live now how
uncivilized are we going to allow our
own world to become in response to so
barbaric and assault we are living I
believe in a frontier time one of the
great hinge periods in human history in
which great changes are coming about at
great
speed on the plus side there's the end
of the Cold War the revolution in
communications technology great
scientific achievements such as the
completion of the human genome project
in the - column a new kind of war
against new kinds of enemies fighting
with terrible new weapons we will all be
judged by how we handle ourselves in
this time what will be the spirit of
this frontier will we give the enemy the
satisfaction of changing ourselves into
something like his hate-filled a liberal
mirror image or will we as the guardians
of the modern world as the custodians of
freedom and the optical and the
occupants of the privileged lands of
Plenty go on trying to increase freedom
and decrease injustice will we become
the suits of armor our fear makes us put
on or will we continue to be ourselves
the frontier both shapes our character
and tests our mettle I hope we pass the
test
mr. Rushdie is now going to answer
questions one thing we're interested in
questions we're not interested in the
speeches in any case are there are their
microphones out there oh yeah okay and
there's one there so when you are you
ready to answer your ask a question just
come to one of the microphones and mr.
Rushdie will recognize me and you have
to come to the microphone because
otherwise I can't hear you and nor can
anyone else
so I'll just stand here until you do if
you could come to one of these mics
please that would be great
whoever gets there first yeah yes sir in
a recent Washington Washington Post op
that article by you yourself you seem to
identify religion as a source of evil in
the world I wonder if you could
elaborate on that thought well I'm
tempted to say look around you
you know that's to say if you look at
and I'm not just even talking about
radical Islam if you if you think I
wrote I don't know if the peace you're
referring to is a piece I wrote about
arising out of the massacres in Gujarat
India by Hindu fanatic mobs which were
just I mean one of the vilest things to
have happened in in India in many years
and the burning alive of children you
know etc etc still I mean when went on
with the with the the government of
India dominated by Hindu nationalists
turning a blind eye to it and indeed
increasing evidence that members of the
state government which is and which is
amiss aim political party as the ruling
party had actually been seriously
implicated in in the organization of
those massacres and of course nobody has
been prosecuted or arrested or anything
so it's Hinduism - it's you know though
I mean Christian Coalition goodness
knows has its has its has its problems
and and of course Islamic radicalism so
my argument was that if all these things
are being done in the name of God then
then to suggest that the name of God is
in any way responsible is to miss a part
of the explanation now of course you
know the private practice of religion is
not my business to comment on you know
that's that's something which people
either do or they don't do and I think
brings them consolation or you know
satisfies whatever it satisfies that's
not my business
I'm talking about the public
interventions of religion and and if we
look in the in the recent world at those
places in the world where religion has
got into the driving seat so to speak
let's take only theron in Afghanistan
you know Iran and Afghanistan we see the
dreadful state of affairs that follows
we see the the extraordinary tyranny
that can be imposed in the name of God
so that's what I said but I meant when I
said that we now know the name of the
problem and the problems name is God
this question goes to one of the finest
storytellers from my country I wonder if
you realize that you have moved far from
the country of your the country that
really inspires you for instance in the
essays on the frontier your concept of
the frontier is very westernized don't
you think that somebody from India from
the subcontinent of India with first of
all when he's talking about the frontier
the margins would think of the Laxmi
Drake huh and don't you think when
you're talking about the frontier
somebody went from your background
should talk about the concept of Sahad
you know it's a highly evocative word
which you have not used even once that's
right because I was talking about the
sense in which the subject now occupies
my thoughts you know and I'm sorry if
it's not sufficiently Indian for you i
but it seemed to me that it did begin
with a serious discussion of the concept
of the concept I'm not talking about you
know some - Asafa chol sense of the
frontier I'm talking about its operation
in my life and in our lives and it's
true that it talks to an American
audience about the American sense of the
frontier and how that's changed and I
mean that's just what it is no it's just
an essay you know it's an it's not it's
not supposed to be the last word on the
subject it's an investigation of the sub
and it may well be that that's an essay
that perhaps you could write impression
that one gets you know that you're
targeting the Western audience and one
more point sir I was wondering why for
readers in India you had a different
cover which is not as attractive as a
one in the well I mean just just to
assure you that it's not to discriminate
against Indian readers that's the
English cover the English edition the
English publishers I agree with you by
the way I tried very hard to persuade
the ink well it's a pencil with a match
of course no no I I tried very hard to
persuade the English publishers to use
this cover but failed to do so they said
it was too late because I thought
actually I found this photograph when I
found it after they decided on the cover
but unfortunately it's the English
edition that's distributed in India and
that's why I was thinking of the notion
of fighting for freedom and the notion
of when one in eight when is it
justifiable to go to war to liberate the
oppressed or where would you draw a line
and and you said not to become
barbarians but no I didn't say that I
said not to well I mean it broadly
speaking yes I said that there's a
problem of whether you become the mirror
images of your enemy that's right that's
that's that was the point I was trying
to make but well I think it's an
important question and and you know one
which no doubt we're all going to be
debating for some time to come but to
give an example of it in the case of the
aftermath of the September 11 attacks I
was strongly in support of the action
that was taken against al-qaeda and the
Taliban because it seemed to me that
that was essential and and probably by
by its having been taken it prevented
further such attacks and it certainly to
use the military term degraded al
Qaeda's ability to carry out
further attacks on that scale and you
can see from the the fall of the Taliban
and the response of the people in
Afghanistan that that was a kind of net
gain for the human race and that the and
that the Afghan people celebrated it so
I think they're there if you like
it seems to me was a clear example where
it was justified - but I think we are
all of us very confused about the idea
of intervention you know about when it
is correct and when it is not correct to
intervene in in the internal workings of
other countries America has been
sometimes criticized for not intervening
such as for example in Bosnia at other
times criticized for intervening for
example in Kosovo and and there seems to
be in the international community and
and in America itself no very clear
definition of exactly what you're
talking about is where is it right to do
this and when is it wrong you know I
think when we I'm hesitating to say the
word Iraq because I suspect it will take
over the conversation but but I think in
the case of Iraq the the idea of
intervention is is greatly much more
problematic and I think at the moment
the justification for doing it in the
way that it is planned unilaterally
preemptively that case is not made to my
mind I'm thank you very much in your in
the wonderful imaginary homelands and in
this book you talk about some of your
influences in fiction and I was
wondering are there any and you've also
talked about movie Directors in that
context I was wondering if there any
poets who also have had equal or similar
influence on your work and that you
think consciously of as an influence oh
very much so you know I think actually
there's a part of this book in which I
talk about the influence on my early
life have even before I'd written
anything of the great or dual language
poet fares I'm at fares who was who was
a close family friend of my families and
who who I grew up with as a kind of
extra uncle you know and in fact
officiated at one of my sister's
weddings and so on so it was a very
close relationship and Fairs was in many
ways not like me I mean for example he
was as you know
perhaps no a card-carrying communist
most of his life and you know winner of
the Lenin prize and all kinds of things
that one might these days find
problematic not so then nevertheless he
showed me an idea of how to be a writer
which I think I just assimilated you
know even even not even consciously it
fares was a great poet perhaps the great
poet of his of his generation and a
writer in many different veins and say
he was a great love poet a great lyric
poet many of his verb his poems were in
fact set to music and became very
successful songs and he became therefore
extraordinarily popular amongst the
masses the people even those who did not
traditionally read poetry
so that was one side of him and the
other side of him was that he was a very
public poet and both in his poetry and
in non non poetic writings he took on
the great subjects of his time whether
they were the partition and its
aftermath or or whatever it might be and
I guess learning we're getting to know
him and and and thinking about him it
just it just occurred to me that that
that was the writers job you know the
way in which he saw it you know was in
fact the writers jargon and I guess he
just became when I found myself becoming
a writer it became natural for me to try
and and fulfill though that double
function as well to be both the private
artist and the public you know more
engaged figure so so that's I think a
poet too is costly important to me and I
think in the you know I could I read a
lot of poetry I actually read a lot of
poetry when I'm writing novels because I
think you know the American critic
Randall jor-el once said that a novel is
a long piece of writing that's got
something wrong with it
and I think there is a difficulty about
a novel which is that it is a long piece
of writing and as a result there's a
great temptation in terms of the
language to settle for easy solutions
just in order to get to the end of the
paragraph or to the bottom of the page
no novelists of course despised poets
because their lines don't go all the way
across the page and and they don't go
all the way to the bottom of the page
and you know they published something 50
pages long and they call it a book so so
there's that natural scorn of the
marathon runner for the sprinter you
know but it but it's true that reading
reading poetry while writing prose is a
way of reminding myself that there is
actually no reason why prose fiction
should not pay the same degree of
attention to the language that poetry
does except that it takes longer to
write it as a result you know does if
you're willing to allow it to take
longer to write then you can write
novels with the same concentrated
attention to language that poets
habitually you know pay to language so I
mean and the list of poets you know
there is is more or less endless you
know and there are many different kinds
and I just would draw attention time
become very attracted recently to an
extraordinary symbiosis between a
previously good but nothing exceptional
British poet Christopher Logue and an
older poet Homer and in Christopher
loges
remaking zuv books of the Iliad there
are just some of the most brilliant
books of poetry that have been published
in England I think in recent years I
think there's so far three volumes each
volume takes two books of the Iliad as
its subject there's a volume called war
music there's a volume called Kings and
at the moment I forget the title of the
third book but they are astonishing
because something has happened in the
meeting of Christopher Logan Homer that
has produced amazing contemporary
English poems you know so yeah I mean
poetry there's lots of it I mean I could
give you a list 100 poets long but but
that'll do I think thanks I have a
question about your characters in your
novels usually they many of them have a
political viewpoint when that it's this
characterized and I'm wondering if prior
to writing the novels you make use of
outlines or other plans in order to in
order to portray that political point of
view that
ends up coming across um not exactly I
do do a lot of architectural work you
know but I do do a lot of work before I
start writing you know just to try and
understand the skeleton of the beast so
I'm trying to bring to life you know
however it often happens if when I
actually write the book that skeleton
starts changing you know and I think
it's a probably a truism to say that the
book you finish is never quite the book
that you start especially if the book
takes a long time you know this
Midnight's Children the Satanic Verses
the ground beneath her feet each took
four to five years you know and and
you're you're thinking shifts in that
period and the trick somehow is for the
book that you've finished to represent
the person you are at the end of the
book you know rather than as sometimes
happens be inconsistent because it's
it's got bits left over from what you
thought five years previously the
purpose isn't ever I think exactly
political and the way the phrase I've
always used is historical because I
think my interest has always been to
suggest that in in this in the modern
world you cannot separate the lives of
individuals from the larger historical
context in which they live you know that
peoples that whereas you know in the
novels of Jane Austen she could write
have an entire career of novels in which
the Napoleonic Wars are almost never
mentioned even though they're going on
exactly at that period the only time
soldiers you know I mentioned in the
novels of Jane Austen know when they're
handsome people in uniforms at dances
and and don't they look good in their
uniforms and that was legitimate because
the lives of her characters could be
portrayed wholly and understood fully
without a reference to the public sphere
which seemed to be happening you know
somewhere quite different well the world
isn't like that anymore that the public
sphere of the private sphere just crash
into each other every day and so it's
always seemed to me that I've got to in
order to explain who the characters are
I've got to show that larger context you
know to give a simple example if if
let's say
a currency speculators attacks your
nation's currency and the currency
collapses and thousands of people
including you lose your job it's it's it
doesn't matter how you've led your life
up to that point you know your life is
changed by that act so the old idea the
idea that's been there really ever since
the beginning of literature the idea of
Heraclitus that a man's a man's
character is his fate the character is
destiny is in a sense not always true
anymore you know economics could be
destiny bombs can be destiny you know a
plane flies into a tall building and
kills 2,000 3,000 people it doesn't
matter how they led their lives did they
lead their lives well or badly that does
not affect their destiny so it seems to
me that we now because we live in in
that age in that age in which the public
sphere can absolutely transform your
life irrespective of how you have led
your life you know that in order
therefore to understand the modern lives
you have to put fine you have to set or
I have tried to set those stories at
some kind of public crossroads in order
to understand them so it's it's that
more than trying to make a particular
political point well what it brings to
the story I hope is a kind of speed and
you know urgency I suppose it started by
my having a sense and my feeling that
many people felt that the world was
somehow going too fast you know that it
that the speed the rate of change the
rate of event in the world had
accelerated to a ridiculous degree and
that literally so to speak our lives
were being lived at a kind of speed
which was impossible to control you know
and I thought having had that idea I
then had the idea of actually making
that you know of making that metaphor
literal in the character of somebody
whose life was speeded up so so so that
that was that was really the germ of the
of the idea and also it came from
another thought that I'd had many many
years earlier not not anything to do
with the mores last sight that very
strange things happen to storytelling
when you make a shift in tempo you know
when you tell a story at if you like at
the wrong speed you take a comedy and
slow it down it becomes oddly
melancholic you know if you take I was
first struck by the story by the German
writer Heinrich von Kleist called the
earthquake in Chile very very short
story it's about three or four pages
long and in it there is a colossal
amount of event all of which is
absolutely horrifying nothing I mean
there's an earthquake in Chile right
then lots of terrible things happen to
most to everybody in the story in fact
nothing nice happens to anyone at all
and the horrible things get worse and
worse and worse and worse and then get
worse and the effect of having this
enormous effect this enormous pile of
horrendous information arriving at such
high speed is it's strangely comic you
begin to giggle as the next catastrophe
hits you know and it's it's as if this
is like speeding up the film it becomes
like a Keystone Cops movie of an
earthquake you know and so I had always
been interested ever since then in
fooling around with the with the tempo
of a story you know in finding ways to
to twist and change the speed at which a
story is told and to see what changes
that made to the meaning of the story
you know and and that also is related to
why the character if by why he lives an
accelerated life
the book outside I've read some like
extremely talkative because you have
cultured in you change
you embrace topics that tend to be not
so focused on self content anymore and
I'm curious why why change well just to
assure you it may not be permanent
I mean look my life has been led in many
different places and it seemed to me
that I wanted to draw on all those
resources in different novels I mean
actually the ground beneath her feet has
a very large section of it that has to
do with with contemporary India you know
but but that's the novel about leaving
it's a norm it's a novel about the urge
to go elsewhere you know and and so the
characters do in the end make a journey
across the world and I mean our you know
my life has been a journey across the
world it seemed legitimate to try and
draw on that experience in books but I
mean I shouldn't say that but the next I
mean the novel I'm doing now has a lot
to do with India so you know I mean my
books just have always gone back and
forth you know and probably always will
but I'm not in some way some way giving
up on India you know because how could I
I've never yet written the book which
didn't have an Indian character at the
center of it you know even even Fury
which is entirely set in the West and
has relatively little to do with India
except as I've got a small piece of the
back story still has Indian characters
that it's very centered you know Indian
characters in the Diaspora because I'm
very interested in the Indian diaspora I
think it's a really fascinating thing
that's happened the way in which people
from India have spread across the world
and changed you know and I mean I
remember the great Indian photographers
friend of mine went did a survey in
India
of in England rather of Indians of
Indians living in England and their
children and their descendants aw and he
was really I saw him at the end of it
that he was really quite bewildered he
said that you know that in many ways
these were people who he found it
difficult to recognize as being Indian
because their culture had shifted so
much and yet they themselves clearly
thought that they were and felt that
they had every right so to describe
themselves and so I think in that
relationship between India in India and
India elsewhere you know that's there's
a very interesting subject there you
know and I just think that is part
naturally part of my subject but though
don't worry about it I'll be back all
right last question
Oh is the actor you like well I'm mostly
Kashmiri as you may know I mean three of
my four grandparents of Kashmiri and the
fourth one was partly Kashmiri so you
know it's it's it's important to me and
you know my view is increasingly that
the thing that that the first great
leader of Kashmir Sheikh Abdullah said
immediately after partition which was
Kashmir for the Kashmir ease which has
always been the view of a majority of
people in Kashmir ever since and is the
only thing that nobody pays any
attention to you know that that might be
the answer now you know